we're gonna move into this which is very
very closely related to significant
figures scientific notation it's the the
notation of choice for surprise surprise
scientists and the reason why is because
in scientific context which is a use of
area commissions and so on
lots of the numbers that we do without
either really maybe or okay therefore it
makes our awkward to write all of those
those dozens of zeros in order to make
another huge or the dozens of zeros to
make a number small so if you have like
an astronomically large non log well
it's fitting because you know when
you're badgering Australia you're like
these distances are mid tens of millions
or billions of kilometers whatever it is
right when you are astronomically large
numbers or microscopically small numbers
like the size of its adenine the size of
an electron or something like that okay
it starts to become a little bit awkward
because you've got something like say 3
million million million kilometers right
oh how is the solar system ok actually
it's much bigger than that
oh you might say alternatively yeah zero
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero eight meters okay
which is like okay this size the width
of the nucleus or whatever it is okay so
what we try to search for is a more
efficient way to write numbers like this
okay now the advantage the sort of tool
that we use to the to make this more
concise is index notation so we just
need to review them okay so make a
little sort of some kind of heat index
notation index notation is what makes
scientific notation work okay
so let's recall if I wrote for you
something you like say to cute
that's an abbreviation what's an
abbreviation for 2 times 2 times 2 2
dosoo it's actually I'm multiplying two
three times okay now we live in a base
10 system a decimal system so every
subsequent number is like tens hundreds
thousands etcetera
so rather than like two to the power
something the power is that I'm
interested in of how is all ten because
that's tens hundreds thousands so is a
second example if I said to you
something like 10 to the power of 4
that's 10 times 10 times 10 times 10
that's 10,000 yeah about count of my
zeros correctly so you can see 10 to the
4 a much more concise way of writing
10,000 how many zeros did I write I
think I said million million million
yeah so how many zeros is that maintain
its some six every time for each billion
in these three of them so that's 18 so
how could I write this number the number
of zeros to get the zeros is 10 to the
a-team that's how many zeros are not but
then you've actually got the size of the
number like it's not 10000 it's 3 0 0 0
so I'm just gonna stick out 3 of the fun
ok so what I've just written up here
this is the scientific notation for
whatever that distance is okay and you
can see much more efficient way to do
things it gets a little bit tricky I'll
do a 30 table here what we want to
introduce negative indices let's go
let's go fine okay no negative indices
maybe I mean wizard a while ago that we
did this okay so this is about dividing
numbers rather multiply them
okay so we're trying to get really small
numbers rather than the big ones
okay now you might have learned which is
to turn this into a positive index or
any more space is to cross the line
change the same I don't know if you ever
learned that so you crossed the line you
got gonna need this works both ways by
the way we've gone underneath the
fraction right so now we're on the
denominator you cross the line you
change the science so it's not negative
five anymore it's fine does that make
sense so what this is sorry I found a
space we can continue going go to see ya
this is 1 over 10 times 10 times 10 that
makes it okay now I asked you to get
your calculators out just now okay you
can go ahead you can punch in any of
these you can punch in 10 to the minus 5
you can do 1 divided by what I'm looking
for is a decimal can someone give me the
decimal point zero point like that okay
so hopefully you can verify this on your
calculator when you're doing this right
I want you to notice because it's a
little bit steep right come and easier
as did I have when I did 10 to the
fourth how many zeros I had 4 zeros 1 2
3 4 how many zeros do I have 4 10 to the
negative 5 5 including this guy over
here right so it's kind of nice if you
remember even if you've got a positive
or negative then the number up here the
power and index that's how many zeros
you're going to see assuming you've got
whole numbers out the phone does that
make sense
okay now please be careful here right
how many zeros do you count
12 - 2 4 6 8 10
Oh bingo okay so how will I write this
number if I had a 1 instead of 1/8 of on
the end there
yeah that's like this number but just
more zeroes you said 12 right 10 to the
negative 12 but in fact it's a lot of 1
there is it it's an 8 so I'm gonna say
don't they
okay now this and this these are simple
examples of scientific notation you
could see if I wanted to
well how many significant fees do I have
on both of these numbers how many do I
have
I just have one significant figure in
each case okay if I wanted more
significant figures one of the things
and you should put this sort of in a arm
and important color one of the things
that scientific notation is that this
number out the front this one that tells
you not the size like how many zeros but
like the actual the ending or the
beginning or whatever okay that number
we want it to be between 1 and 10 okay
so for instance you wouldn't write if I
if I suddenly went somewhere there was
10 times further away you wouldn't write
30 times 10 to the 18 right because
that's not between 1 and 10 if I had 30
times 10 to the 18 that 30 is actually 3
times 10 there's another 10 that I can
write in there right so this in fact
will be 3 times 10 there are 18 tens
hiding in there and here's one more so
therefore I'm gonna have in total 19
okay so you see this line here not
scientific notation because the numbers
not between 1 and 10 right and it makes
a few pairs apart this number this is in
scientific notation does it make sense
okay that's all let's let's just do that
shall we okay now a way I could do this
is to say all right well this is instead
of three times 10 to the 18 I could say
well it should be 13 times 10 to the 18
yeah like I've replaced the 3 with the
13 but again this is not scientific
notation because it's not between 1 and
10 so I need to divide this number by
something to make it between 1 and 10
I'm gonna say it's one point three times
ten to agree with that you can verify
the calculator if you like you know how
we move the decimal place and so on
there's already that 10 to the 18 that
was hanging out the back there so now
again I've got 18 10 there I've got one
here in total I have 19 tens so this
this last line that's scientific
notation yes yes no no make sense